is a taliban takeover of afghanistan now
inevitable no
it is not
wow that didn't pan out
one year ago today the taliban swept
into kabul and seized total control of
afghanistan after president bayh had
made the decision to withdraw american
troops trey ingst is live in kabul hey
trey how you doing
hey greg good afternoon today the
taliban took a victory lap piling into
pickup trucks and driving through the
capital of kabul take a look at this
right now the taliban is parading
through the streets
of kabul
they're marking one year
since the takeover of afghanistan
you can see these fighters here
celebrating
many civilians though remain
in hiding
uncertain about what comes next
for their country
as his mother last year has been
anything but a celebration for the
afghan people when you look at the
situation on the ground the economy has
collapsed plunging millions of people
into poverty women's rights have
decreased and the security situation
remains fragile but when you walk
through the streets of kabul there is a
sense of routine and normalcy there are
street vendors selling food there's
traffic people are out and about but
behind that veneer sits uncertainty and
fear for afghan civilians especially
those american allies who were working
with the united states during the last
20 years we spoke with the taliban
extensively about their views on islamic
law and also women's rights and
education but we had a very interesting
conversation with an official from the
foreign ministry this week when i
pressed him on the taliban's view of the
u.s drone strike that took place last
month taking out the leader of al-qaeda
i'm in al-zawahiri take a listen
late last month the leader of al-qaeda
ayman al-zawahiri was killed in a u.s
drone strike in kabul
did the taliban know he was here
the islamic emirate of afghanistan made
it very clear that the leadership
was not aware of either
his arrival nor his presence in kabul
and they will continue to
conduct
the investigation
to verify
facts
but the fact of the matter remains that
this was a grave violation of
international law by the united states
of america
conducting unilateral actions inside a
sovereign state
the bottom line is you can't take the
taliban at face value you can't trust
what they say when you interview them
but the most important thing here is the
civilian population especially those who
were u.s allies working with the united
states and when we were here last year
on the runway at kabul's international
airport when those evacuations were
taking place
we thought this couldn't get any worse
for these individuals they have to leave
their entire lives behind and if they
can't get on those planes they have to
stay here but we are back a year later
and things have gotten worse and they
appear that they are getting worse each
and every day for every person here
under taliban control greg thank you
trey
so will i want to
try to distinguish between the decision
to leave which trump had signed i mean
this was something we're doing and how
it was carried out in which you couldn't
do much worse
and i think can you can you separate
those two
you know i don't even know if you can
separate the exit from the 20-year
debacle that was our investment in
afghanistan yes we can criticize and we
should criticize the exit because to
your point greg i don't know that it
could have been done worse the estimates
are 800 american citizens left behind
clearly no plans no long-term plans no
organized plans to get us out so what
was accomplished before that
catastrophic exit um whatever it was we
gave it all back in 12 months time
i mean women's rights are gone um you
know al qaeda has a presence clearly
with ayman al-zawahiri there at the time
and my big takeaway is yes it's worth
looking into the past but also why don't
we let it inform the president and the
future and the same group that's so
advocated for our presence and even our
exit in this manner from afghanistan was
the one itching to go into ukraine
you know richard i mean
you are nodding along and i think that
what is the lesson learned here about
something that we were holding and then
the moment we left it all returned the
way it was there is a lesson in there oh
there's definitely a lesson and i think
the lesson is two three-fold i think
lesson number one is our lawmakers have
got to be more thoughtful for 20 years
yes people lap up a lot of blame at joe
biden and fair enough those criticisms
are fair but think about this for 20
years members of congress approved
budget after budget after budget and
nobody has to say so you say there's 300
800 8 000 uh afghani troops can i go
look at them can i see them are they
there clearly they were not and i think
what makes this so frustrating for me is
that this war started when i was a
freshman in high school i am now 35
years old this country lays in ruin
american blood was spread all across
this country these were my classmates
these were my neighbors these are my
friends and now we're sitting here and
watching this country go into a dismal
collapse and the question i'm asking
myself similar to will is why were we
there in the first place and we're also
dealing with the fact that there was so
much mission creep at first it was we're
going to get bin laden then it was we're
going to go build a democracy then it
was we're going to surge then we're
going to take them away then we're going
to surge again and the american people
were left in the middle trying to figure
out what's really happening in
afghanistan
i think you know
dana by just listening to to both of
them it's something about you can't
really
make any progress if there's no
prosperity in a country it's like you
try to think
they're going to be like once they
figure this out but if they have no way
then it's always going to revert back to
what it was story from all around the
world right that's why one of the
reasons when kamala harris says she's
going to latin america and she's going
to figure out the root causes you
actually have to figure out one
corruption yeah that is a big issue
education is a big issue and part of
that is if you're going to make 50 of
your population not allowed to leave the
house without being fully covered you
can't go to a doctor if you're a woman
you're not going to be able to be
educated you're going to suppress 50
of your capital human capital you're
going to have problems when um when
president biden decided to do this uh
his poll numbers the way that he did it
the poll number is never recovered
that's just true you can look at it it's
just like they went down they got to a
point where people said we can we are
embarrassed by this incompetence
and then everything else started
happening as gas prices continue to rise
and inflation increase um conditions
were not being met that president trump
set out he said we will leave if this
happens those things that were supposed
to happen were not happening and they
left anyway as you saw with sam and
salman rushdie
our enemies and people against freedom
are very patient
okay so like for us we're like oh since
i was a freshman in high school take it
anymore and i get i absolutely get it
and there is an obligation on behalf of
leaders to say this is why we're doing
this this is why it matters that went
away and so so we have that i would i
would add this in addition to the 800
citizens that were left 96
of special immigration visa holders the
people who actually were on the ground
the afghans who helped us along with our
forces who helped save their lives they
didn't make it out
and right now at the state department it
would take them 18 years to deal with
the backlog that they have so the the
incompetence continues on at the
bureaucratic level um
dagon i was told that this was the new
improved taliban
i'm extremely disappointed
you are i'm a woman yes
you identify as a woman
today yes
you're going to get me in trouble aren't
you um to dana's point i looked at the
poll numbers the overlay of approval
versus disapproval august 20th is the
day that his he went from net approval a
net approval rating to a net disapproval
and joe biden has been deep in the red
ever since then because of to dana's
point his
incompetence i call it his stubborn
stupidity
but also on full display was how he
blithely lies to the american people
over and over and over again repeatedly
and i think that that was what turned
americans against him when george
stephanopoulos says your top military
leaders
warned against withdrawing on this
timeline no they didn't no they didn't
yes they did u.s troops he biden said
u.s troops will stay in af and stay
until all americans are out of
afghanistan
no they didn't al-qaeda's gone from
afghanistan no it's not our allies are
with us no they weren't if you're an
american you can get to the airport no
they couldn't over and over and over
again he stood up in front of the
american people and lied and a lot of uh
so many people just said we're done we
don't trust you
there's the devil and they wanted credit
for the largest airlift in history yes
that's amazing here's our screw-up it
broke records okay
up next even some democrats are having
to admit texas migrant busing strategy
it's pretty brilliant i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now